robert valdez gets the ball for the
astros today and fromber he's really
been a workhorse since coming off the
injured list but had a rough one his
last timeout against oakland and now
it's luke voight's turn the first
baseman
he's hitting 245 316 on base percentage
three homers and 11 runs batted in
maldonado going through the signs let's
judge at third and stanton at first for
the yankees
two outs the one-two swinging at a miss
can't hold up on another curve ball
three straight to voight and the inning
draws to a close
yankees had three base runners in the
inning but they do not score
and after a half inning yankees nothing
astros coming up jamison taion on the
mound for the yankees product of the
woodlands it's going to be the first
time he has ever pitched as a major
leaguer at minutemade park now two-way
here is right-hand hitting first baseman
julie gorielle
guriel hits the ground ball to short
gleiber taurus fields and throws to
first in time nice play by voight
stretch to get the low throw and that'll
do the inning no runs one hit
now it's the mayhew he walked his first
time he fell behind o2 wound up seeing
eight pitches and got the free pass
mrs robert walked two in the first he
was helped by le mayhew getting a race
trying to go from first to third on the
ball they got away from maldonado first
pitch here ground ball right at garcia
shortstop will take it to second and get
the force to end the inning so the
yankees a couple of hits but no runs and
after one and a half astros nothing
yankees nothing
now two-way here's the other rookie in
the infield robel garcia and the [ __ ]
caught anonymous high fastball struck
him off swinging
in the inning no runs no hits one left
end of two no score
top of the third inning no score with
the yankees and astros from valdez back
out there
and he'll face aaron judge to lead off
the third inning he walked his last time
up three infielders
on the left
now this three and two now to judge
kicks and delivers and it swung on and
missed
ellen elevated the pitch there and judge
swung right through it the batter now
will be stanton who singled his last
time up just a a chopper over the first
baseman's head here comes z02
and a swing and a miss and it gets away
from stanton he can't go to first
because it was occupied it's a strikeout
but on the wild pitch goes sanchez to
second
well here is glaiber taurus he has chew
on and two men out
here in a scoreless game top of the
third
here is torres
torres hits it hard and it goes past the
shortstop garcia into left field sanchez
being waved home to throw not in time
sanchez scores and the yankees take a
one-nothing lead
so ershell is the batter
2-2 swinging a miss
strike three that'll end the inning
on that curveball lowing in the fourth
strikeout for valdez and gives up a
unearned run here in the top of the
third and we've played two and a half
yankees lead one now
our team aldonado leads things off for
the astros bottom of the third here's
the 1-2
that balls hit well
right field slicing into the corner
judge going back and it's gone
maldonado
sixth home run of the season for martine
and that breaks the skids for the astros
their first run of the series
hey nothing there
altuve flight out to left field his
first time up
now here's the 2-2
and the pitch cut out of miss
good low fastball that was
and tim lo castro lead it off so the
yankees send up eight nine and one the
castro drives that to right field tucker
back looking up and it's gone
the ithaca bomber deposits one out to
right
and gives the yankees the lead back
it's two to one thanks to la castro
gary sanchez the batter
o2 strike three got him looking on the
breaking ball right on that outside
corner and that's the third out and here
is the young center field to chas
mccormick
and the pitcher mccormick is cut out a
missed on a breaking ball so he strikes
out robel garcia the shorts out with
runners at second and third two out
it'll be a 2-2
and the pitch curveball struck him out
swinging
so
that's the fourth strikeout for tayo no
runs no hits
two left
at the end of four two one yet
uh here's gleber
and the pitches hit hard base hit left
center field going toward the alley
stanton goes to third and
he's coming on home
so stanton scores voigt goes to third
as gleiber taurus delivers a basin and
an rbi and the yankees take a 3-1 lead
so two out and runners at the corners
for brett gardner who has a single and a
ground out
3-2
swing and a mess got him on a curve ball
in the dirt and the inning is over
scrub punches the pocket of his glove as
he walks off
and the yankees strand a pair they get a
run on torres rbi single and after
four and a half yankees three astros won
kyle tucker the batter he grounded out
in the second walked in the fourth taion
working from the first base side of the
rubber
delivers
and tucker cranks it pretty deep to
right judge is going back looking up see
you later
kyle tucker goes deep and the astros are
down by a run three to two tucker's 15th
of the year here is o'shella with two
outs and a runner on oh here's the 3-0
swung on and lined right field it's a
base hit tucker picks up he fires home
it is gonna be not in time
taurus slides in safely it's a 302 up
base hit by ashelah and the yankees take
a 4-2 lead here's le castro their left
fielder he's
homered he's one for three
four to two lead for new york
here's the one one
broken bat and it's going to be a one
hopper altuve who is shaded toward the
bag and he throws out
the speeding le castro for the third out
so a run in for the new york yankees and
we'll go to the seventh inning stretch
at minute maid park it's new york for
houston too well here is gary sanchez
all right here's the o2
swung on and hit in the air to deep left
field it is high that is far er it is
gone
the crack and cracks one
gary sanchez has opened this game he hit
a three run home run over the high
scoreboard wall into the crawford broxas
and he also pulls his shirt a la judge
hala altuve a three-run ho oh that gary
is scary he hits a three-run blast and
the yankees take a 7-2 lead here's tim
lecastro ninth man to bat in the inning
there's only been one hit in this inning
the three run home run by sanchez
stanton off third void off second or
shella off first
three two
strike three call at the knees on the
outside corner le castro thought it was
ball four
may have had a beef but the inning is
finally over
yankees
leave them loaded they get three on the
homer by sanchez and after seven and a
half yankee seven astros two so one out
and gary sanchez stands and he had that
three run home run in the eighth
one two to sanchez that's a ground ball
left side that's right at toro goes to
second for one altuve on the first
that's a double play and the inning is
over
so garza walks a couple but gets out of
it
and we go to the bottom of the ninth
yankee seven astros two
mccormick flat out to deep right as last
time the one oh to green are from green
and mccormick drives it deep to left
center la castro is going back it's over
his head and off the base of the pillar
in front of the visitors bullpen guriel
scores tucker right behind him two run
double for chas mccormick and the astros
trail seven of four astros need another
base runner to get the tying run of the
plate is abraham toro stands in oh for
two
two one
and toro hits it in the air pretty deep
to right center judge is going back at
the wall he leaps he can't get it it's
off the fence in front of the astros
bullpen mccormick races around third he
will score toro in the second with an
rbi double seven of five yankees
so toro at third straw at first
representing
the tying run and jose altuve at the
plate representing the winning run jose
is oh for four
so far today the 1-1
and altuve hits it in the air pretty
deep to left going back as la castro at
the wall looking out see you later to
the lighter sea liner
astros winning at the bottom of the
night
hold the l2 by the walk off homer
eight to seven astros
they were down by five
in the bottom of the ninth
and altuve's 20th home run of the year
is a walk-off winner
and it's deja vu all over again and how
about this jose altuve's jersey is torn
off he is bare chested
how do you like that